en 1902 kodock frais que publie le
deuxième volume du groupe que est un
ouvrage ambitieux qui vise à enfin posé
les fondements de toute les
mathématiques à partir d'une théorie des
ensembles mais frayeur reçu alors une
lettre mystérieuse de pet food vous à
sal russell
il utilisait les fondements de frais que
pour construire le pire monstres de
l'histoire de mathématiques
à lui seul ce monstre anéanti toute la
théorie de frais que quand frigo compris
les dommages de ce monstre dévastateur
il a couru à la maison d'édition et
ordonna la red l'impression de son livre
l'éditeur de frais que fut bouleversée
des années de travail était en jeu il
supplie frais que de bien vouloir
accepter la publication de son ouvrage
malgré tout frais que dépité fini par
accepter mais dans un élan d'honnêteté
intellectuelle absolument remarquable il
rajouta le court message suivant en
ouverture de son livre il n'ya pas grand
chose de plus indésirable pour un
scientifique que de voir les fondations
de son travail s'effondrer juste au
moment où son travail est achevé
c'est dans cette position que me mit une
lettre de monsieur bertrand russell
quand mon travail était sur le point
d'être publié
l'effondrement d'une de mes lois ce à
quoi mène le paradoxe de monsieur
russell semble détruire non seulement
les fondations de mon arithmétique mais
aussi les seuls fondation possible de
l'arithmétique pour comprendre le
monstre de russell il est utile de faire
un petit détour par l'un des programmes
les plus célèbres et des mathématiques à
savoir le théorème de kantor qui dit
qu'il existe plusieurs un goût différent
ljs incessantes vous ont déjà parlé de
ce fameux théorème
aujourd'hui on va en voir une preuve
légèrement différente puisque on va
travailler avec des nombres réels entre
0 et 1
mais écrit en base 2 et en particulier
on va montrer que l'ensemble des réelle
écrit en base de entre 0 et 1 ne peut
pas être listé avec des nombres entiers
naturels
considérons donc une liste infinie de
nombre réel écrit en base 2 va montrer
que cette liste est forcément incomplète
ce que l'on va faire c'est entouré tous
les chiffres de la diagonale puis
inversée les 1 à 0 et les héros en
obtient alors un nouveau nombre réel est
bien ce nouveau nombre réel ne peut pas
avoir été dans la liste qui étaient
fournis en effet notre réels diffèrent
du premier nombre par son premier
chiffres après la virgule
il diffère du seconde par son second
chiffre et plus généralement il diffère
du énième nombre de la suite par son
énième chiffres après la virgule notre
réel et donc forcément absent de notre
liste initiale notre liste était donc
incomplète
voilà qui montre qu'il n'est pas
possible de lister les nombreux réel
l'ensemble des nombres réels et en un
certain sens trop grand pour être listé
avec des entiers naturels en termes plus
techniques
on dit qu'il n'ya pas de bis g ctions
entre les entiers naturels et les
nombres réels donc et ça c'est vraiment
cool mais est-ce qu'on peut aller plus
loin est ce qu'on pourrait pas
construire un ensemble infinie encore
plus grand que l'ensemble des nombres
réels et si la réponse est oui
quel est le plus grand infinie que l'on
peut construire
voilà une question passionnante et bien
la réponse est non et pour comprendre
pourquoi est ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on va considérer n'importe quel
infinie super grand et montrer que alex
est infinie on peut toujours construire
un infini encore plus grand
un peu comme pour montrer qu'il n'y a
pas de plus grand nombre ce qu'on fait
ce qu'on suppose qu'un nombreux n est
très très grand on montre qui ne peut
pas être le plus grand reconstruisons un
nombre plus grand par exemple n + ans et
dans le cas d un fini on va montrer que
si on prend n'importe quel ensemble un
film x très très très très grand alors
je peux tout reconstruire un infini
encore plus grand que l'on va appeler p
2 x et qui va être
l'ensemble des sous-ensembles de x par
exemple si x et l'ensemble chats souris
alors les sous-ensembles de x seront
l'ensemble chat qui ne contient que le
chat l'ensemble souris qui ne contient
que la souris d'ensemble x lui-même qui
contient le chat et la souris et enfin
l'ensemble vide qui est bien un
sous-ensemble de l'ensemble x on peut
représenter tous et sous ensembles de x
en explicitant si oui ou non ils
contiennent respectivement le chat et la
souris
ainsi l'ensemble ça correspond à 8 non
l'ensemble souri à non oui on semble x
ah oui oui et enfin l'ensemble vide
correspond à non il ne nous reste plus
qu'à montrer que si x est un infini
alors p 2 x est un infini strictement
pour grand montrer cela ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on va montrer que toute
façon de lister les éléments de pbx à
l'aide des éléments de x forcément
incomplète
par exemple supposons que x est un
ensemble infinie d'espèces animales
l'ensemble vide est le sous-ensemble des
espèces animales qui est obtenu en
rejetant tous les éléments de x
autrement dit il est représenté par la
suite
non non non non non non à l'infini
al'inverse l'ensemble x et le
sous-ensemble de x qui accepte tous les
éléments de x entre ces deux extrêmes on
a diverse ensemble qu'ils acceptent et
rejette plus ou moins d'éléments de x
essayons maintenant de numéroter notre
liste de sous-ensembles de x à l'aide
des animaux de x ouvrez les verts pour
montrer que cette liste est en fait un
complète on va construire un
sous-ensemble en inversant tous les
éléments de la diagonale ce
sous-ensemble ne peut pas avoir été le
premier élément de la liste puisqu'il
diffère dans son adhésion de premiers
éléments de la liste il ne peut pas non
plus être le second élément de la liste
car ils diffèrent dans l'adhésion du
second élément de la liste plus
généralement notre sous ensembles ne
peut pas avoir été associée à l'élément
x 2 x car ils diffèrent dans l'adhésion
de
et ça ça veut dire que toute liste de
sous-ensembles 2x ordonnée par des
éléments de x est forcément incomplète
en termes mathématiques
on dit que toute fonction de x d'amp et
de x est forcément nom sur chaque tive
ou dit encore autrement
l'ensemble p 2 x est toujours forcément
strictement plus grand que l'ensemble x
et ça ça veut dire qu'il ne peut pas y
avoir deux plus grands infinie tout
infinie grand x est toujours strictement
plus petit que l'autre infinie p 2 x et
ça quand vous y réfléchissez
c'est complètement fou parce que ça
paraît si tonton de penser qu'il y à un
plus grand 1 finit par exemple
l'ensemble de tous les ensembles que
quand tu aurais gaudeul appelait aux
médias aux médias donc est ce qu'il ne
serait pas par hasard
forcément le plus grand de tous les
infinies ah oui tout ensemble x contient
des éléments et oméga contient tous les
éléments donc oméga contient tous les
éléments de x donc forcément oméga est
au moins aussi grand que x et donc oméga
est le plus grand de tous les ensembles
sauf que on vient de montrer que
week-end est forcément aussi strictement
plus petit que p2 oméga l'ensemble des
sous-ensembles de l'ensemble des
ensembles on a là un paradoxe fatal à la
théorie des ensembles de frayeur si un
ensemble était juste une collection
d'objets mathématiques comme frigo
l'imaginer alors on aura forcément un
ensemble de tous les ensembles qui
serait le plus grand infinie mais qui
serait aussi strictement plus petit qu'à
notre infinie ce paradoxe est ce qu'on
appelle le paradoxe de russell en fait
le paradoxe d'euros sol légèrement
différents mais ils s'appuient là encore
sur l'argument de la diagonale
dévastatrice de kantor
l'astuce de russell fut de lister tous
les ensembles avec eux mêmes en effet en
décrivant chaque ensemble par le fait qu
ils inclus ou exclu les autres ensemble
on obtient un tableau avec une diagonale
par le même argument que précédemment
l'ensemble qu'on obtient en inversant
les valeurs de la diagonale ne peut pas
avoir a été ainsi listé cet ensemble que
l'on pourrait appeler l'ensemble
r pour russell l ensemble des ensembles
qui ne se contiennent pas eux mêmes à la
tête de penser à cet ensemble
en effet si c'était un ensemble qui se
contenait lui même alors il y avait un
oui dans la diagonale et l'ensemble air
consiste à changer ce wii en un nom et
du coup x n'appartiendrait pas à
l'ensemble
r1 inverse si x ne se contient pas
lui-même alors il y avait un monde en
diagonale l'ensemble air consiste à
transformer ce non en oui
et du coup oui x appartient bien à r
maintenant la question qui a détruit
l'oeuvre de frigo et à la question
suivante
est-ce que l'ensemble air appartient à
lui-même bien si air appartient lui même
alors il ne satisfait pas les critères
d'admission à l'ensemble r et du coup
air n'appartient pas à un père mais
c'est inverse si elle n'appartient pas r
alors que satisfait du coup les critères
d'admission à air et du coup air à
partir la terre on a une équivalence
débiles qui me dit qu air appartient à
l'air si et seulement si air
n'appartient pas à m
on a donc une contradiction au sein de
la théorie de frigo et ça ça veut dire
que la théorie de frigo est pire que
fausses ailes et inconsistant l'aderf on
a parlé de l'axiome du choix et j'en ai
profité pour illustrer tout ça avec des
lapins capturé par un suprême fasciste
et à plusieurs parmi vous qui ont trouvé
le concept de suprême fasciste amusant
voire proche du point godwin
en fait le concept de suprême fasciste a
été inventé par mois c'est une hommage à
paul r dos comme des plus grands
mathématiciens du xxème siècle qui
aimait parler de ce suprême fascistes ou
sf pour raconter des énigmes
mathématiques tarn et chanel propose que
tous les lapins à et mordiller le
suprême fascistes avant qu'il ne les tue
et ça c'est marrant parce que ça
ressemble un petit peu une façon de
raconter un problème par paul ehrlich
justement rapport à une énigme de la
théorie dite de ramsey vous vous
imaginez un grave ou très grave c'est un
ensemble de points avec des arrêts
contre tout père de pondre un programme
complet et la question que l'on se pose
c'est est il possible de colorer les
arrête de ce graphe en bleu ou un rouge
de sorte que si je prends n'importe quel
trois points de ce graphe et que je
considère juste les arrêts entre ces
trois ponts par le dessous graff induits
je veux qu aucun des priants le comédien
comme ça aucun des souks graff à 1,18 à
trois sommets soient monochromatique
donc je ne veux pas qu'il y ait de son
graphe monochromatique et donc si on
prend les petits graf
si on prend un grave quatre sommets
c'est assez facile de trouver une façon
de colorier les ponts pour qu' il n'y
ait aucun sou graff induit deux à trois
sommets qu'ils soient monochromatique
que se passe-t-il maintenant si les cinq
semaines et bien je vous invite à
trouver une façon de corée les arêtes
que ce graphe en jouant mieux de sorte
qu'il n'y ait aucun sou graff induit
monochromatique et je vous invite
surtout à vous demander quelle est la
taille que doit avoir ce graphe pour
qu'il devienne impossible de faire des
coloriages des arêtes sens où graff
induit moins de chromatique
bref ce problème a été résolu dans le
cas des souks graff induit à trois
sommets mais on peut du coup aller plus
loin à ce qu'on ait que se passe-t-il si
on passe au sucre afin de lui à quatre
semaines quelle est la taille minimale
que doit avoir le graf avec laquelle on
a commencé pour qu'il ne puisse pas y
avoir de façon de le coloré sans laisser
de son graphe induit à quatre sommets
monochromatique et ce problème là aussi
a été résolu la réponse et 18 si vous
prenez un graphe du jso mais alors il
n'est pas possible de colorer césar est
sans avoir de son graphe induit
monochromatique et si on a dix-sept vous
pouvez et du coup la question qui
viendra bien sûr juste après c'est
quelle doit être la taille du graff pour
qu'il n'y ait pas de sou graff induit à
cinq sommets qu'ils soient
monochromatique la r2h dit ça c'est un
problème très difficile aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs on sait que la réponse
quelque part entre 43 et 40 merdo je
pense que si le suprême fasciste nous
donner un an pour résoudre ce problème
sinon le détruire à la terre
eh bien on pourra mettre tous nos
meilleurs chercheurs là dessus et on
finira sans doute par le résoudre en un
an
cependant si notre suprême fasciste nous
demandent de résoudre ce problème en un
an pour la valeur 6 pour les souks graff
induit à 6 sommet erdoes conseille
d'aller attaquer directement suprême
fasciste parce que le problème
mathématique est juste beaucoup trop
difficile et on a plus de chances de
s'en sortir en tuant le suprême fasciste
sinon il ya eu quelques mets
compréhension dans le problème que
j'avais posé dans les deux problèmes que
j'avais posé donc c'est clairement ma
faute j'ai pas très bien expliqué donc
une première précision a ajouté c'est
que les lapins ont le droit de dire que
blanc ou noir n'ont droit qu'à un seul
mot et ils entendent ce que disent
qu'ils sont passés avant eux et n'ont
que ça comme informations au moment où
ils doivent deviner la couleur de leur
chapeau ne peuvent pas dire oh mec juste
devant être au fait de thierry noir des
mecs les deux avants maintenant on a
droit juste un seul mot chaque lapin le
droit juste à dire de dire blanc ou noir
peuvent se réunir avant que les chapeaux
leur soit donné pour préparer une
stratégie mais bon faut que les chapeaux
ont été données une fois qu'ils ont été
alignés puis lorsque les chapeaux leur
ont été données voilà ils n'ont plus le
droit de communiquer tout ce qu'ils ont
le droit de dire ces blancs noirs et
autres choses bien sûr les lapins ne
savent pas quel est le monde de chapeau
blanc et noirs et donc vous avez été
assez nombreux à résoudre ce problème
alors pour résoudre ce problème il
fallait y aller avec une question de
parité de ce que dira nombreux pères de
chapeau blanc en fait ça personne ne
peut le savoir
mais le lapin qui est tous derrière qui
voit tous les chapeaux sauf le sien il
est capable de savoir si parmi les
chapeaux devant lui il ya un nombre pair
de chapeau blanc n'ont donc il en fait
tu veux juste content et donc de chapeau
blanc s'ils ont deux chapeaux blancs et
perd il va dire blanc et s'il est un
père il va dire noir et là je vous
laisse deviner finir le raisonnement le
lapin qui va être deuxième position il
va pouvoir prendre l'information
savoir s'il ya un nombre pair de chapeau
blanc devant lui en comptant lui et puis
il est aussi capable de voir le nom de
jappo blanc devant lui et à partir de ça
est capable de connaître son chapeau et
puis je vous laisse déroulé le
raisonnement pour en conclure que lui le
troisième lapin sera aussi capable de
déterminer son propre chapeau étant
donné les deux réponses qui ont été
données avant lui et ainsi de suite
dans le cas infini où il fallait
utiliser l'action du choix j'avais dit
que les lapins en fait pas besoin
d'entendre ce qu'ont dit les lapins
derrière eux mais donc ça c'est vrai
mais ils ont besoin de connaître leur
coin ça c'est vraiment important
ça peut être très clair dans la vidéo
précédente je le précise tombe et se
demande s'il est possible pour la
supprime fasciste de choisir les
chapeaux des différents lapin s'il n'a
pas lui accès à l'action du choix non
plus il ya du choix il faut il a payé
pas l'accès et ça ça revient un peu à se
demander est ce qu'on a le droit de
choisir un nombre réel de définir ce
qu'on peut définir un nombre un réel
puisque la place des chapeaux blancs de
noirs on peut remplacer pour sa part des
chiffres 0 1 sont basses finnair et puis
on pourrait même imaginer ni couleur du
chapeau où chaque couleur correspond à
un chiffre entre 0 et 9
bref vous voyez que le point de choisir
et chapeau c'est un exactement le même
que celui de choisir un nombre réel et
ça ça pose directement la question de
monsieur eric à savoir est-ce qu'on peut
définir les nombreux réel sans utiliser
les actions du joueur
et la réponse est oui oui qu'est
beaucoup de choses marche très très bien
son excellent du show où tout ne marche
pas super bien on a des trucs bizarres
savants et les nombres réels mais les
nombres réels globalement et existe
indépendamment dans l'action du choix il
existe dans la théoriser daf notamment
et puis il existe aussi dans des
théories plus faible que de la théorie
des ensembles ou des trucs comme cela et
on en parlera bien sûr beaucoup plus
quand on parlera des maths
constructiviste témoins et notamment du
débat entre un tuyau nist et classicisme
stage platonicien frédéric mazoir ajoute
la remarque absolument stupéfiante
suivante qui est le fait que le problème
du suprême fasciste avec une infinité de
l'art est résolu bhl si à la place
d'avoir des chapeaux blancs et noirs
chaque lapin avait écrit sur son crâne
sur l'arrière de son crâne pour que les
lapins derrière eux puissent avoir un
nombre réel ou un truc incroyablement
compliqués qu'ils devaient deviner
là on peut dire deviner un nombre réel
c'est impossible normalement veut dire
qu'aucun lapin n'est capable de deviner
son propre nombre derrière son crâne
et bien pourtant avec l'axiom du choix
tout voire même raisonnement exactement
le même preuve que celle que j'ai donné
tous les lapins sauf un nombre fini avec
utilisation direction du choix et
histoire du capital et tout ça tous les
lapins sauf un nombre fini seront
capables de deviner le nombre réel qui
est écrit sur leurs crânes ce qu'est ce
qui est complètement fou passé
normalement on était impossible de
deviner nombre réel est là une infinité
de lapin presque tous un sofa n'en finît
seront capables de deviner et ça si
c'est pas une preuve calcium du choix il
faut quand même qu elle espère que
j'avais mais c'est l'épisode la
prochaine soit en valais un petit peu
plus loin des paradoxes et on parlera de
quatre autres paradoxes de la logique
mathématique
si vous avez aimé c'est l'épisode penser
à le lac et à le commenter à le partager
pensez à vous abonner pour ne pas
manquer les futurs épisodes merci au
type un polar dont et j'espère que je
verrai la prochaine fois la conclusion
de kantor c'est que le cardinal des
nombreux réel bah c'est aussi l'infini
mais c'est un infini qui est vraiment
strictement plus gros que celui dont on
a parlé jusqu'ici faire l'infini
indénombrables cette question ap les
hypothèses du continue à trouver sa
réponse en 1963 lorsque paul cohen
annonce qu'en fait
chacun peut choisir si oui ou non il
veut de cette infinie intermédiaire